the Russian lawyer for a Michigan man
jailed on espionage charges in Moscow
says his clients detention is baseless
Paul Whelan a former Marine was arrested
in Russia a week ago and accused of
spying he was formally charged yesterday
Wieland's family denies he's a spy Jan
Crawford is outside the Russian embassy
in Washington with this continuing
mystery Jan good morning well good
morning so Paul Wieland's Russian
attorney told us he expects him to stay
in a Russian prison at least until the
end of February although he has asked
for bail Whelan has been in that jail
now for a week in solitary confinement
he is asked for an english-speaking
cellmate he doesn't speak Russian very
well and he's been having to use a
translator he's also asked for some
clothes and even a toothbrush now his
family said this all started because he
went to Moscow for a wedding of a friend
and intelligence the State Department
sources tell CBS News they are confident
that Whelan is not a spy they think they
somehow gotten unwittingly caught up in
the spy game and that Russia is just
using him as a pawn to try to get back
one of its spies maria butanna who is
now in a US prison on espionage charges
now we talked to CBS News national
security contributor Michael Morell he's
deputy former deputy director of the CIA
and he told us that this arrest should
be a warning to any American who's
thinking about going to Russia now is
not a good time to go to Moscow Anthony
Jan thanks yeah and we should note that
Wieland's lawyer is reported to have
close ties with the Kremlin as well so
we'll be following this story obviously
what difference tell me what that means
well he's a criminal defense attorney
which you would imagine any other
country would be an independent attorney
right as opposed to one who's affiliated
with the government or in this case the
FSB the Russians a security department
got it